hello sponge heads i'm tom kenney the
voice of spongebob squarepants
and i am here with the cast of the new
spongebob movie
sponge on the run here listen to them
they're really here
that proves it and today we are going to
be looking at your spongebob
redesigns from the draw off instagram is
everybody
i ready it that is like that is like
alfred newman from mad magazine and
spongebob
yeah i thought it was like an ice cream
treat that started to melt
the term bar fly comes to mind
mickey mickey rock for all my friends
for all my friends
jacques i like that one got a kind of a
mystery face to him there
i love him it's kind of got that cool
old pen and ink slash woodcut
feel um except i don't know that uh
they had polo shirts uh cracking with
polo shirts yes yeah
i don't even know if they had polo did
you know that the polo shirt was
actually discovered by marco polo on his
voyages and then he brought them back
amazing
george lucas how does he feel that is
darth i i'm a big enough of a nerd to
know that that is darth maul
this lightsaber isn't sweet enough
you're full of sif
you guys are all full of stuff
[Music]
jesus she's looking
fine michaela hey carolyn he got your
hair cut down in that last uh
that last photo on the bottom right
[Laughter]
you actually did have that haircut for a
little bit i did i let my kids shave my
head so
that was that
what's that what's that famous movie the
iron giant
yes no yeah isn't it i love it
i am not gunning i i do want to hear vin
diesel uh voice
spongebob like he did the iron giant
superman
there's a lot of kevin's in the in this
world i'm noticing bye kevin
i have to say it hi kevin oh yeah
wow emo squidward
i like emo squidward like
you do not want him taking your order at
the krusty krab
no you don't no no that pose is right
before sullen teenage squidward says
i didn't ask to be born dad yeah right
okay you don't understand oh yeah
that is nice that's awesome i appreciate
all the beauty that is a norwegian that
is a female norwegian zoftig uh a female
patrick
wow and janelle i like that i think i
think that's yeah that's
that's patrick's got that working i i
think so yeah
i think our demo on this show is
changing oh
great oh wow it's a pancake wow
ever wow that's cool so so it's
definitely a
a 2d medium hope the colors are
non-toxic that's going to make for some
weird looking poo for a couple of days
wow misty i want to have a full-on
costume made of that and then wear it to
a furry convention
make it for me i'll wear it to comic-con
next time
that kind of has like an ariel feel
right it's kind of kind of got that
little mermaid you know
there's a song coming on here
right insane clown posse that's great
that's like spongebob has a juggalo
i love it andy warhol's frankenstein
right
i got the good looks and he's doing the
chicken meme you know
pose which is great extra points extra
points for combining the terrifyingness
of clowns and the scariness of the
internet in one
swell foop that's it so many great
drawings so many great takes on all
these characters man you guys
imaginations know no bounds and it never
fails to impress
all of us thanks to everyone who
submitted their drawings and if you want
to take a better look at these drawings
or
stare at that creepy clown one uh just
to give yourself nightmares
uh be sure to follow draw off on
instagram at
draw off show that's the little abe in
the circle
draw off show one word no caps
[Music]